vous savez quand les enfants ils partent
traumatisent les chats leur nom comme ça
tout le monde est là c'est bien une
bonne idée
[Musique]
elle aussi elle est un nom de princesse
la princesse de la Guerre des étoiles
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît
elle est très paresseuse
elle aime bien venir dans le lit mais il
faut que je la prenne pour qu'on ne
vient pas tout seul madame il faut la
prendre il faut s'occuper beaucoup
d'elle elle aime ça à ce qu'on peut de
moi mais moi il faut que je m'occupe
d'elle elle veut que je l'adore l'autre
je l'aime bien
elle aime beaucoup les haricots verts
elle aime se baigner sur le robinet elle
boit toujours sur le robinet madame
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est lui qui commande
[Musique]
pour les yeux c'est ma grand-mère
moi c'est les oreilles
ma mère c'est pour le brosser chacun sa
partie
et après c'est à Minouche
mais le nom de mes filles Carmaux comme
ça je les ai toujours avec moi vous
savez quand les enfants ils partent le
baptise les chats de leur nom comme ça
tout le monde est là c'est bien une
bonne idée
vous avez pas pensé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il sait ce que vous faites
[Musique]
quelque chose une fois il a compris
je suis en train de manger toute seule
et il arrive avec sa petite balle jaune
pour jouer
qu'est-ce que vous faites
quand même mon petit repas et puis ben
on
court après
ma balle cours autour du lit autour de
la table autour des
[Musique]
un film
un cochon d'inde depuis gens qui peuvent
pas voler
c'est pas fait pour vivre en cage c'est
normal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui n'est pas bien
[Musique]
un peu de crevettes donc c'est plat
alors
maintenant un bon récompense est une
petite crevette
[Applaudissements]
personne suivante pour les consultations
et le matin c'est ce que j'ai retenu
comme je suis assis sur le côté elle
vient m'appeler pour gérer dormir avec
et c'est drôle c'est c'est comme ça il
faut pas cacher la nature d'un chien
vous comprenez
non parce que on dort pas avec eux c'est
pas possible on peut pas dormir avec un
chaton
moi je peux pas avec eux je peux pas
dormir c'est pas possible
avec une pièce maintenant que je suis
bien logé ils sont aussi bien tout seul
[Applaudissements]
et puis si je dormais avec eux avec la
java qui font
maintenant que ils sont tous en truc
ça se termine ce soir ils ont bien fait
d'en profiter
parce que maintenant on est dans le
petit chien
alors celui-là
[Applaudissements]
mais j'ai peur que ce soit la
fin j'aime bien attacher cette belle
surtout que l'année passée j'avais perdu
mon mari
en plus
[Musique]
ça fait longtemps que vous l'avez ça
fait 14 ans
surtout qu'il est tellement gentil il
est doux il sait pas mort il est très
gentil même le vétérinaire m'avait dit
qu'il faisait leurs expériences sur des
bigles comme ça
moi je suis quand même la maîtresse de
qui on se méfie de temps en temps quand
même oui parce que le journal sur le
derrière il sait ce que c'est
le châtiment
l'homme est une sale bête c'est ce que
je pense d'une façon générale à
l'humanité heureusement il y a quelques
exceptions qu'on rencontre ici dans ces
lieux
bon j'étais là couché avec ma copine
dans le dans les buissons tu vois bon
puisque c'est là qu'on me remets alors
je vois j'entends dans les forêts comme
ça
une tête comme ça
et merde au fait c'est toi qui a mon
chien
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors vous attendez
le vétérinaire
[Applaudissements]
je rentre qu'est-ce que je vois ma télé
par terre
parce que
je m'en fous ça me débarrasse
[Musique]